[Música]
economía en directo América me acompaña
en el estudio Juan Pablo lucumí Juan
Pablo muy buenas noches mencionábamos
esas sanciones que propuso imponer la
Unión Europea a Rusia profundicemos de
qué se trata Santiago Buenas noches pues
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula vonder Legend propuso este
miércoles imponer lo que llamó sanciones
duras al comercio Ruso y direccionar la
represalias a los funcionarios
responsables de los recientes referendos
de anexión a Rusia de las regiones
separatistas de Ucrania dentro de las
sanciones destacan las prohibiciones de
exportación del bloque hacia Rusia para
privar al complejo militar de Moscú de
tecnologías claves como componentes
electrónicos y sustancias químicas
específicas además sin profundizar en el
tema Wonder Legend también dijo que
había que establecer la base legal para
un tope de precios en el petróleo ruso
Pues recordemos que el bloque ya acordó
prohibir a partir de diciembre El crudo
proveniente de Rusia por el mar la
propuesta que incluye a 1.300 personas o
entidades rusas aún debe ser respaldada
por los 27 de Pues de este bloque Esto
fue lo que dijo la líder Europea
ndo
No aceptamos el falso referéndum ni
ningún tipo de anexión en Ucrania y
estamos decididos a hacer que el kremlin
pague por esta nueva escalada esto
mantendrá los productos rusos fuera del
mercado europeo y privará a Rusia de
unos ingresos adicionales de 7000
millones de euros
Juan Pablo esta serie de sanciones
contra Rusia Cómo han afectado la
economía de este país Santiago Pues
según el Ministerio de desarrollo
económico de ese país la economía rusa
se contrajo un 4,1% el mes anterior
estamos hablando de agosto si lo
comparamos con los tres meses anteriores
hay una leve mejoría Pues el producto
interno bruto en julio fue de 4,3%. en
junio fue el más alto de los tres con un
5% en la contracción de la economía y en
mayo del 4,5%.
moscúa pronosticado una contracción
mucho menor escuche esta cifra del 2,9%
para final de este año Aunque
la realidad es que expertos esperan que
sea del
4,3%. el presidente Vladimir Putin ha
sido muy optimista con el panorama
económico y en varias ocasiones ha
aplaudido como la economía de su país se
ha remontado a las sanciones de
occidente pero ya veremos qué ocurra con
estas nuevas sanciones que la Unión
Europea planea desplegar pasamos ahora a
hablar del Reino Unido porque las
autoridades económicas de ese país Ya
empezaron a tomar algunas medidas
tratando de estabilizar los mercados
británicos Por qué las autoridades
intentan evitar una crisis en la
economía general luego de que los
inversores se asustaran tras el anuncio
del jefe de la cartera económica en el
que habló de un programa de recortes de
impuestos no financiados acto seguido la
libra esterlina se desplomó frente al
Dólar y el costo de la deuda pública se
disparó las alertas llegaron porque el
estímulo fiscal aumentaría la inflación
que de por sí ya está alta y Por ende a
un aumento de los tipos de interés
además todo esto pondría en riesgo
credibilidad del país ante los
inversores entonces dentro de las
medidas para evitar ese panorama el
banco de Inglaterra dijo que compraría
bonos del gobierno a largo plazo Durante
las próximas dos semanas para combatir
una caída y el fondo monetario
internacional tomó la rara medida de
instar a abandonar el plan de reducción
de impuestos una recomendación que no es
común y menos a una de las economías más
fuertes del mundo ya veremos como les va
entonces Juan Pablo pasemos ahora
indicadores como las faldas principales
bolsas en la jornada de hoy tenemos
noticias positivas Wall Street por
ejemplo se recuperó este miércoles y
cerró Precisamente en terreno positivo
además de otras razones las acciones
subieron debido a que el rendimiento de
los bonos del tesoro de Estados Unidos
registró el máximo de la última década
los mercados europeos también siguieron
la senda alcista de Estados Unidos y sus
tres principales indicadores reportaron
ganancias en nuestra región la bolsa de
comercio de Buenos Aires cerró Este
miércoles con una medida del 1,88% luego
de una jornada en la que el ministro de
economía de Argentina dio a conocer ante
el parlamento el proyecto de ley de
presupuesto para el 2023 y para el
cierre la cifra del día cuéntenos
82,50 euros por acción Ese es el precio
que Volkswagen fijó este miércoles en la
cotización final para el automóvil de
lujo Porsche con esto la compañía Busca
demostrar que la icónica marca de autos
deportivos puede superar la caída de los
mercados capitales lograr la mayor
oferta pública inicial en la última
década y tal vez contar una de las
contar con una de las cotizaciones más
grandes de Europa Ahí está para que se
compre el último ya veremos Gracias Juan
Pablo es todo por el momento aquí en
economía en directo América a
continuación el debate
[Música]